today we will be donating one hundred
thousand dollars to twitch streamers
that's a lot of money it is this dude's
bench pressing dude this dude's jacked
okay i got it
every rep you do on the bench i'll
donate 500
he looks like he can do a lot bro for
every rep on the bench you do i'll
donate 500.
he currently has 225 pounds on the bar
and every rep
is 500 oh there he goes he's getting his
suspenders on
if he does 100 i own 50 000 all right
one
two three four
keep going it shouldn't be this light
that's more than i weigh
he's benching me like it's nothing three
carls he's been dressing
you can do it he's so far made 10 grand
and he's still going
that's all i can do without hurting
myself brother i don't have a spotter
this dude just made ten thousand dollars
a raptor ten thousand five hundred
you're
a strong boy let's see his reaction look
at his face
look at him well i'm hyperventilating mr
beast thank you so much brother
thank you so much bro that's like
literally all of my duck just gone
oh this young in here is playing geo
guesser basically a sponge
a random place in the world and you have
to guess where you are if you guess
the correct country i'll give you ten
thousand dollars
is this a troll is that a troll mr bees
just followed me
oh nope camera if he guesses the correct
country he gets ten thousand dollars oh
no i'm never gonna get this one
i'm never gonna get this so we're
allowing his sister to help yes
japan look at that so he thinks that
text is from japan
he said it might be in east asia and he
said what about china or japan though
all right this is a ten thousand dollar
guest is that japan i think
i'm gonna hope it's japan
are you don't want to think more
oh my gosh i can't wait to see his
reaction to this donation
ten thousand dollars say hi
to youtube he just got ten thousand
all right i'm gonna end the stream thank
you so much all right bye
he just ended his stream and then he hit
you with a thank you mr beast
she's about to play a game of fortnite
let's go if she wins
i say we donate 10 grand and if she
loses we give her nothing
sound good sounds good if you
win this game i'll donate 10
000 it's a lot of pressure i wouldn't be
able to do it i wouldn't be able to do
it because i'm not good at fortnite
if you win this game i'll donate ten
thousand dollars good luck this would
help so much we just bought a house we
closed at the end of the month i gotta
put my mr beast
on ben she has beast merch mr beasley
this is she's dreamed of this moment
before oh she should just bush camp the
whole time
is that not a strat anymore maybe like
three years ago dude she's about to die
off the spawn yeah she's around so many
people
she's got this first game on it's their
first game on they're rusty watch this
i'm gonna get this kill for you mr beast
watch this well they're just kind of
standing out in the open like that yeah
fifteen thousand dollar game of
fortnight nothing crazy
oh no no no no i missed my shot
please don't die oh oh nice nice nice
nice nice it's good it's good he's on
the roof
under you jenny i'm finishing him up
all right well they all died look i got
sweatpants i'm about to just put them on
double sweatpants
she's already wearing sweatpants she's
gonna be sweating a lot she's a madman
mr beast donated five thousand dollars
because you're a fan i gotta hook you up
we just bought a house and he's
literally like that helps so much
no crying we love you mr b
we love you mr b thank you dang i wish
you won now
i know i really wish you won jenny
before we give more money to other
twitch streamers take these phones
whichever one of you gets the furthest
by the end of this ad i'll give your
grandma ten thousand dollars go
they have the sponsor of this video on
crash on the run chris grab those wombat
fruits faster
we got money to make for my grandma i
already beat the level oh
the game's experience is unique only to
you wait how
that's the magic and on top of that in
this app is a wide range of characters
it's wide you can play as crash
bandicoot his sister coco
fate crash and many other characters
wait fake crash you mean he's not real
ow i already finished the second level
did you take the shortcut carl i didn't
need to
the app just went live today today if
this seems interesting to you click the
links in the description and download
crash
on the run right now chris do you just
hate your grandma
grandma i love you well not enough
congratulations carl you just won
ten thousand dollars for your grandma
we're gonna go give more money to twitch
streamers i'm gonna keep playing
carl give him a random challenge let me
see his background he's clearly on a
yacht in the ocean
on a yacht yes clearly prove you were
actually
on a yacht because he wouldn't lie about
that he wouldn't just stand in front of
a green screen
that'd be insincere oh lego
look wait what jack twitter it's real mr
beast just followed you
i did i did just follow him
he's only said swear words yo mr beast
he wants a boat party
get ready put your speedos on let's hit
it
how does this prove he's on a boat i
believe that doesn't prove you're on a
boat man
you're right this is unrefutable proof
he is on a boat he's going all
out oh my gosh she's gone all out this
is the most work anybody's ever put in
for your money
i'm putting on a damn show thanks
for the undeniable proof
that you are on a boat
he just saw the 10k donation now that
his dance party's over
whoa he's flipping what the hell how
much
ten thousand dollars how much ten
thousand how much
yo i don't have donations turned on
because nobody ever donates
shut the front door shut the front door
ten thousand
ten thousand like a broken record player
just thank you thank you
thank you so so much no problem man and
now we're on to the chess side of twitch
with nemo
we found her not the fish if you
win your next game of bullet chest
i'll donate ten thousand dollars wait
what
it actually is him
oh she's freaking out oh boy she started
she's getting right into it
she has no time to think it's the most
stressful version of chess
honestly i'm not even gonna act like i
know what's going on oh this is
terrifying
holy cow look at how intense she is
thinking she hasn't said anything in
like 20 seconds
oh no but they're losing time oh she's
going to win
[Music]
oh my gosh that was insane my freaking
heartbeat i just said the 10 dollar
donation because she won
you are absolutely insane thank you so
much mr bees thank you since birthday
gotta celebrate
think about this tenth sally bomb it's a
hundred dollars oh that's a hundred
thousand
let me get rid of a zero i heard today
is your birthday pay now let's see if
that ten thousand dollar donation goes
through do they lock my credit card or
do they send the donation
huh look at his face i heard today is
your birthday
oh my god look at him no this is not
happening is it wait
what is this real there's too much
happening right now
i'm going to donate half of it donating
half of it to charity
let's go the beast 1 000
glad you're happy man you're amazing
thank you
i'm gonna help my mom jesus i can help
my mom with stuff in here
not crying my eye just itches we have
our next streamer here what's your
favorite number
69. all right sixty nine hundred dollars
six
nine hundred make sure you tell him it's
cause me this stop
was my idea carl
there it is he's shut down what wait a
minute
oh my god it was perfect guys it's in my
paypal
yeah because i donated it like i don't
know if it's legit
it is real congrats man
yo my boy mr beats with a thousand more
i'm confused mr peace i watch all your
videos i love you so very very very
very much okay another five thousand
dollars
my 5 000 donation went through and he's
not even there
you've gave him 13 grand look it doesn't
even fit in the box anymore
oh my god
i'm glad you're happy man carl pick the
next streamer okay up next we have tubbo
but not tobo this is mom we got tubo
at home r u tubbo
mr beast are you tubbo what it's a
serious question
that is 720 pounds i don't know what
that means maybe that's how much a
thousand dollars weighs maybe i've never
weighed it i sent the donation
get a diamond in the next 60 seconds and
i'll donate 10
000 shut the front door holy crap
no don't get out of your chair get the
diamond in the next 60 seconds i'll
donate 10 000.
yeah well actually now you only have 45
seconds help me get a diamond does this
count
this doesn't count surely no he's not
picked it up you don't have a damage he
said diamond i got a diamond
okay i'm going to add another layer on
it all right it's 60 seconds to build
another portal if he does i give him ten
thousand dollars
never thought they'll never thought the
nether portal get the dream music
something about the music you got 50
seconds
is anyone a chuckle obsidian oh god i'm
i'm panicking
40 seconds go go one flint boys we got a
flint
we got an iron come on there you gonna
build it 30 seconds
one two three one two
three there we go thirty seven thirty to
forty
start it yeah in some 60 seconds
all right i can't wait to see how he
reacts to this
[Music]
they just give me 7 200 pounds mr beast
you can have my
you can have my grandchildren now that
i've secured his grandchildren how we
can end the video
goodbye click the subscribe button